[Music]
so from my end-user perspective
this like fashion jewelry and picks or
the backcorner buttons and if you look
at the very best technologically
did and dessert or a family celebration
seamlessly in the bathroom
safari sample i know you using your
phone or idea president s and sarah
understand how to see pps operation and
when she's transmitting DNA in this lot's
or I liked the samples there
technologically for the us in the
accountant may want to do them and the case
or bitcoin exactly emulate a ladder
and a new garmin pak de la
is rhianna rand financial services please
persians him a new dds act as a and
site think way the raw uses this can
be this will end up being a part of a
free page porfolio engineers and urine
have simple porsche and
in balance and simple potion and starks and
the simple portioning pretensions
fighting for most people but love
scanning for Christians in Rotterdam
some people there fucking building your
interior internet ri contents already
infrastructure it in a flute over the
two values ​​that centralize crypto
currency b systems and much more
skeptical data and refinisher from
centralize and impaired big ass
systems can the Biedermeier play more
efficient and the central assistant
other words if you look at the greenhouses
groningen central system is with slory
humbugging power
inhibiting the and the long hardware you him
economic games and so could you go the
projects great prizes
and if it's the system's running
with simple centralize bridge
Being dharmic is the most bold times
jurgen and siebe hutchens pop-up
is when using some things is unique
who you ssc this was him
and if you ask why do but she knows that
really kinds of
after database with the aspirin
characteristics for a resolution and
pink christmas and other words you can
in the actual
the consensus can be your decisions together
to conclusions there is another power DVD
collective transaction and rescuer tanks
and how we use the new power station for the
king control and being people there that I am
know the system is effectory
censorship
test for caesar resistant another
words the government can come and take
care of you and country which is very
good governance or
and crime and record politics and sammy
action that resulted in a new one
character production studio vision
construction and therapy with a chance
to come up and feel a the tank scored
sediments government would take family
and that door man or garmin another
political family or place where my eyes
and national privacy run for him now
the public and the beer and many of them
to be your own personal
nco on and when he thinks oh so
seriously and back and abbey most a package
requirements of children's show of religions
we have those who have choose
so push connections for polio
[Music]